tell us about losing your ball
uh in 1991 he's got one of you but you
yeah okay in 1997 i was snowboarding in
new zealand and i
i overshot a jump i did a frontside 360
which you're like
the last one that you're blind of and so
like i came around and like just landed
really flat and and got a double hernia
that's where your
gut wall opens up on both sides and or
your stomach wall opens up and lets some
of your guts through and they
get squeezed wow and you can kind of
like push it back in there but it just
keeps popping out and it's like this
horrible like the blood flow gets taken
away or something so like i'm like ah
they're like you need to go to the
hospital i'm just gonna fly home and do
it
so i should have went to the hospital
there because i didn't know but my nut
cord was
strangulated in there too so i came back
here got the surgery wake up
and there's this horrible stinging
sensation like what the hell and they're
like oh sorry we had to
take one of your testicles out they just
told you out like her well yeah i was
out for the surgery i'm like wake up i'm
like what where is it
i want it and they're like so like you
signed uh you know we can throw all
medical waste away
that's not what i would have done i'm
like it's not medical waste this is my
ball
like give it back
aldehyde and put it on my my mantle or
something like that
people say you only got one ball i got
two there's the other one right there
i actually oh then so anyways yeah then
they said i could have babies but i had
four so [ __ ]
doctors never listen to what a doctor
says about you know they tell me so many
[ __ ] up [ __ ] over the years
the uniballer is the most prolific child
bearer or but this is the other idea the
other day like
like i should have got that ball
cremated and then made into an egg timer
[Laughter]
yeah yeah i kind of want when i die why
don't i just wait into a giant sand
timer oh that'd be cool
yeah do people do that that's really i
don't think i don't think ashes
work like sand okay i don't care i still
want to be happy
there's a broken sand what is that but
what does that feel like when you lose
the ball like does it feel like getting
kicked in the nuts
have you ever heard of when people get
an arm taken off they get go slim
they feel like the limb still there yeah
phantom limb yeah phantom limb
i felt like that i would be like i swear
it would be there like what what
it's just not there but it feels like
it's there it hangs right in the middle
really no this one's still waiting it's
still hanging from that body
right
like you can move into the middle it's
like no no he's coming back is there
like a little bit of
sack on the missing side no it's kind of
just or it's just like
it's kept me really high i'll tell you
that oh yeah when it gets cold what
happens
the other one tries to crawl back inside
and what happens to you
i gotta show you this tattoo design i
came up with oh wow
the extra testicle i like that yeah
that's really good well it looks like
he has a weird hairdo
that was an underwhelming reaction dude
i think this is the funniest [ __ ]
thing that i've ever come up with
yeah if it was even two it would be
extra
yeah guess what i have the number 30
ranked hot sauce on all of amazon it's
called stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole
and if you go on amazon and type in
stevo's hot sauce for your butthole
and order yourself a bottle you'd be
really helping me
because right now we're ranked number 30
on all of amazon
and if you buy a bottle we might go up
the ladder
and that would mean a lot so please get
on amazon
and buy stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole
yeah yeah
dude